a very warm welcome everyone
i would like to welcome you all to this
webinar on bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
this program is dedicated to the study
of viral diversity and its role in
epidemic infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging including zoonotic spill
over transmission between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
development
the participants of the program will get
a chance to learn bioinformatics and
analyze genomic data by applying various
analysis approaches to study viral
genomes and as a result you will learn
to understand relationships between
viral strains and haplotypes find
differences in sequence data and see the
implications for drug and vaccine design
this program will provide opportunities
to practice analyzing data to gain
hands-on experiences with curated data
sets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about about
virology
to introduce myself first of all my name
is sunalika ray and i am the omislogic
community manager i am responsible for
daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community that is managed
by pine biotech
for those who are joining us for the
first time let me quickly introduce us
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic training has been completed by
over 10 000 participants from 162
countries in over 300 workshops and due
to this fast growth our team is working
with local and racial coordinators that
are helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
the programs follow a project-based
learning approach
using research-grade tools to analyze
data from top peer-reviewed journals the
training has been completed by six
in six different specialization tracks
which includes oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
so this was about us and our motto
behind the training programs
now let's start by signing up
to the learn.omiklogic portal this
educational portal will help you get
started on your bioinformatics journey
and as a part of this program the
participants will have the access to the
omixlogic courses which includes courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python and
the structural aspect of biology that is
chem informatics
as a part of the program you would also
have the access to the example project
of different fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work
throughout the course you will be given
directions to access the t bioinfo
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analysis of transcriptomics data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
so now let's go to the learn.omixlogic
portal and sign up quickly that will
help you go through the various
resources that our mentors will be
taking us through in today's webinar
so i request you all to please
put in the link of the porter
learn.ormixlogic.com
on your laptops or if you're connected
via mobile phones and make sure that you
sign up on the portal and have an
account for yourself to access the
various resources
now those who have already created their
account on the portal can let me know by
putting in one or yes in the chat box
and others can go through the portal and
create an account for themselves we'll
be giving them a minute or two to do the
same
let me also follow the steps to assist
you
if you click on the login button you
will be redirected
to sign up on the portal
either by creating an account yourself
you can just simply put in your details
and create an account or you can also
login by any of your social media
accounts
thank you ashwini jamil and erandra for
quick response in the chat box
others who have also completed their
sign up please let us know in the chat
box so that we can proceed further
i see a lot many quick responses
so for those who have completed their
sign up on the portal
the next step for them is to complete
their profile so you need to click on
your mail address this will redirect you
to your profile tab where you need to
ensure that you have an updated profile
picture your social media accounts
should be connected and also add a brief
bio about yourself
it could include your educational
background and your research and trust
for every coursework that you complete
on the omixlogic loan portal you will be
getting the points that you can review
here that will take you from a business
level to an advanced level
and being a part of the bioinformatics
for infectious diseases program you will
be able to see a badge on your profile
tab that will ensure that you have the
access to the program page and the
resources associated
now before i hand over the stage to our
mentors to discuss more about the
curriculum
i would like to launch a poll for all of
you so that we can know uh
about you all your educational
background and your research interests
as well
i hope the poll is visible
oh jessie can you please confirm
yes yes
thank you
so my first question here is what is
your educational background
are you a graduate
a post graduate
or a phd or a postdoc
what all are your research interests
from the options mentioned here
is it infectious diseases
oncology precision medicine
agriculture neuroscience or space omegas
also what is your level of understanding
about bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
do you consider yourself to be at a
beginner level or an intermediate or
advanced
my fourth question is what type of
infectious disease data analysis do you
want to learn
is it ngs transcriptomics
or ngs metagenomics
or genomics or machine learning for ngs
data or structural biology data
and my last question is what do you seek
from this program
online infectious disease and data
analysis training only
or also
a research component along with the
training
or mental guidance and one-on-one
support
or would you like to work on an
independent research project
after the successful conclusion of the
program
we'll have the pool
on for more 30 seconds
thank you for the answers
if you have answered the point you can
make sure that you complete your profile
till then i'll just hand over the stage
to our mentors in
30 seconds from now
okay so now i would like to invite mr
ilya brodsky to please take over the
stage over to you elia
thank you very much malika are we going
to end the poll
yes i've done that
okay
all right let me share my screens so
thank you everyone for joining today
it's exciting to be here this is one of
the programs that i think is very
relevant to what's going on all around
us so
it's not unusual that we have so much
interest
let me briefly introduce why
bioinformatics for infectious diseases i
mean why do we need a special program
that is called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases how do we
think about infectious diseases compared
to other types of diseases and
conditions and then i'll briefly
introduce you to some of the challenges
that are still being a hot topic in this
area of research and then i will pass it
on to the mentors on the program that
will speak about some of the technical
aspects including some of the case
studies that we will use throughout the
program
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a training program designed
to introduce students clinicians and
researchers to the role and the
applications of bioinformatics to the
study of pathogenic microorganisms and
their interaction with the host which
lead to and enable human disease
and our understanding of the
pathogenesis of these diseases can lead
to meaningful interventions
interventions like antiviral drug design
or maybe vaccine design we'll talk about
this in just a few more minutes
so in this webinar what we'll do is
we'll use some of the examples that are
case studies that we source from high
impact publications
and extract from their examples of
meaningful application of bioinformatics
methods of analysis to different types
of omics data including genomic data
transcriptomic data metadata genomic
data and others and so what i'll do in
my part of the presentation
is i will give you a glimpse of how some
of these different methods of analysis
are used and have been developed to be
applied to understand and intervene in
these kinds of diseases including some
of the additional challenges that are
still being researched and how we can
leverage the publicly available data
sets that are out there to be able to
ask these questions of uh of
relevance and importance to what's
happening right around us
so the infection itself
what is it and why are we speaking about
infectious diseases as a whole category
of applications of bioinformatics so
infection is the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents their
multiplication and the reaction of host
tissues to the infectious agents and the
toxins that they produce
so an infectious disease is also known a
as a transmissible disease or
communicable disease and it is an
illness that results from the entry or
the actual infection and replication of
that pathogen so the infections that are
caused by infectious agents called
pathogens or include
viruses
as well as agents such as virus which
are not exactly viruses bacteria fungi
parasites
and then they are different from
non-infectious diseases which are also
recognized as chronic and can be caused
by such factors as the environment
nutrition lifestyle as well as genetic
inheritance so we typically think of
them as two separate categories but as
we will see today they actually have a
lot in common and one can be the result
of the other
so the replication of pathogens in the
host leads to major interference
starting from membrane disruption as in
the case with viruses and the release of
toxins as the case of many bacterial
pathogens maybe of these many of these
interferences include molecular
biological pathways that are designed to
fend off intruders and signal to
neighboring cells of danger
the pathogens can modulate these
pathways and cause long-term organ
damage such as lung tissue scarring due
to the immune hyperactivity so
understanding of these biological
mechanisms
the way that the entry happens the way
that the body responds the way that the
viral and bacterial pathogens can
take and modulate those are all the
subject of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases because most of this
information comes from data
so let's take a look at some example
publications
to see
how
this has been monitored and studied
using different types of omics data
so the first example i want to bring up
is the outbreak of ebola virus that
happened in the
2014-2016 outbreak in west africa and
led to almost real-time genomic
surveillance of this disease
as a result genomic technologies were
shown to be effective and useful in an
outbreak of an epidemic
and led to significant interventions
like the discovery of antiviral
compounds and design of vaccines and so
as a result of genomic surveillance
better understanding of the disease and
intervention was a meaningful success
that shows how valuable genomic data is
and therefore bioinformatics which
allows us to study this kind of genomic
data and find meaningful insights in
this data
another example that i have here is an
example from stars cove two so obviously
living in the pandemic the role of
genomic surveillance allows us to answer
key questions about where did the virus
demerge from
how is it developing over time and how
can we anticipate future directions for
this viral replication evolution in
order to be more effective at the types
of interventions that we can implement
including the testing of whether
standard interventions that we think are
effective or advanced interventions that
we might not think are effective at all
could be applied in a meaningful way to
contain this pandemic
another example that you can see here
is the genomic surveillance of
plasmodium phosphorus which is malaria
that is endemic in some areas of africa
and
still to this day after millions of
deaths
has not been
addressed using new vaccine so to
understand this specific pathogen
genomic surveillance is being used also
to understand various factors that lead
to greater transmission
replication severity of disease and as a
result we can see how interventions are
being developed and tested that are
becoming more and more effective to
contain this disease
another interesting article that is
fairly recent is the increased
serological response against human
herpes virus 6a which is associated with
risk for multiple sclerosis this idea
has been proposed back in the 1990s but
only recently have there been validated
studies that show that indeed there is a
statistically significant association
between human herpes virus
and the development for multiple
sclerosis which leads us to think about
many other types of diseases that we
think are purely neurological or perhaps
genetic and and
a result of somatic mutations like
cancer but in fact are caused by
different types of infectious agents
pathogens for example here are the seven
known viruses that cause human cancers
so an estimated 12 to 20 of cancers
worldwide are thought to be
resulting from tumor viruses so we're
not only speaking about infected
diseases that can be monitored and
studied using omix data we're also
speaking about other diseases that we
haven't asked about what
paused through but those associations
are started to be
important to understand
so those were viruses what about
bacteria
bacteria are another pathogen some
bacteria could be pathogenic and
interestingly you can see this article
here that was uh from 31st of january in
2022 the staggering
toll of drug resistant bacteria which
talks about a global survey that shows
that in 2019 antimicrobial resistance
killed more people than hiv or aids or
malaria so not only do we see that
viruses parasites but also bacteria is a
major cause for global health
not only that we also see that drug
resistant tuberculosis poses a major
risk to global health security and we
all hear about antimicrobial resistance
in hospitals of new superbugs that are
not even known how to be treated so this
area of research is not only interesting
is not only relevance of the pandemic
that we're living through but it is also
a major direction for anyone who is
interested to apply bioinformatics
skills and data analysis skills to
address major challenges that we face
today and will continuously face in the
future
one of the interesting things about the
different pathogens that we discussed is
that naturally our body already has a
response to many of these infectious
pathogens
hosts can fight infection using their
immune system the mammalian hosts react
to infections with an innate response
often involving inflammation followed by
an adaptive response vaccines are used
to train the immune system to identify
pathogens and store the necessary
epitopes for antibody production in the
long term immune memory
but due to a variety of factors such
immune responses can be insufficient on
their own
two main approaches that have
significantly reduced death from
infectious diseases in the past century
are the antibiotics antiviral drugs and
vaccines
in fact if we look at the timeline
we can see that the vaccines have been
discovered first but many other
ways to intervene have reduced
significantly the risk that infectious
pathogens
cause
or
pose so here you can see
from the 900s all the way to 2000s this
is the rate
of infection which is a per 100 000
population per year
you can see here simple interventions
for example uh
health departments establishment of
health departments or continuous
municipal use of chlorine in water in
the united states
you can see the
kind of how specific diseases that we
think maybe are
you know well into the past have
actually not been so uh long ago so this
is the influenza the flu pandemic that
killed millions of people a plague
that was uh
last observed here in the 1920s
the use of penicillin if you think of
penicillin as something that was you
know discovered long ago you can see
that actually that was in the 1940s so
not that long ago and the first vaccine
that was introduced in the 1950s
so all of this is recent history this is
the history that many of us have uh
our parents go through our grandparents
through we know that these things have
happened very recently and a lot of the
developments that we are using today are
based on these kinds of interventions
but
over the
since we see such tremendous decrease in
these kinds of pathogenic diseases one
might think that well we've mastered
the way to train our immune systems and
protect ourselves from these pathogens
but in fact we see that covid19 has
proved all of us wrong
here you can see uh this is a comparison
to different other causes of death and
covet 19 surpassed all of them which
shows clearly that we have not mastered
the art of interview or understanding
and being able to effectively intervene
with these uh different pathogens
however what does give us some promise
so bioinformatics i think is one of
those disciplines that allows us to be
to stay
you know somewhat optimistic about the
future of infectious disease research
and the reason i say that is because
with covet 19 what we have seen is the
continuous application of biotics and
data science to
practical interventions that are being
used in real time and are being used to
adapt a response quickly to this
dramatic threat that we now understand
much better and we know how to intervene
much better as well
what is bioinformatics bioinformatics is
the intersection of computer science
biology and statistics and what i mean
by that is that we are able to apply
algorithms and software rely on
databases of different types of data and
use these data science skills to be able
to analyze data but this data isn't
meaningful unless we understand the
biological context and so the biological
context the specifics of infectious
diseases the pathways the different
pathogens the biology of the interaction
between the host and the pathogen all of
those are a critical component for us to
be able to ask meaningful questions and
find answers that are significant and
relevant to the type of data now in the
middle of that our statistical and
machine learning or analytical skills
that we need
and those analytical skills primarily
are driven by our
new structure data and then ask
questions that are generalizable these
questions they're not only relevant to a
particular study they're relevant in
general to some biological phenomena
so
one of the important things in the
context of infectious diseases is that
particularly in this area there has been
a dramatic increase
in the number of data size
data
databases and data types that are
available for infectious disease
research so here you can see this is a
slide from maybe a few months ago but
you can see here that the rate of
discovery of viral genomes the way that
these databases have become structured
and accessible is increasing
dramatically and that means that we can
start asking meaningful questions about
all of these types of questions that we
might have that we just learned about in
a fairly easy and user-friendly way and
so the purpose of training in the
context of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is to start thinking how can i
ask an important question what kind of
examples can i follow and where can i
find data sets that provide me with
sufficient answers that i'm looking for
because even though so much has been
already done
not everything is clear in fact we know
that the diseases that are caused by
pathogens vary significantly between
individuals locations or even whole
populations
they happen at different speed at
different severity and the understanding
of how they happen is linked to a very
deep understanding of the immune
responses as well as the evolution of
these pathogens
and not only that we also are now
discovering that many of these viruses
and emerging pathogens are actually not
only
in
individuals but they also are uh in the
environment they're all around us
they're in other animals and other
species and so we have to expand our
understanding of this molecular biology
to also be able to detect specific types
of
pathogens like viruses
in other environmental samples that we
might not have thought of yet and that
leads us to this major challenge of
annotation and curation of data to
understand relationships between strains
species and viola of different pathogens
and our ability to then understand their
function how do they function how do
they interact with the host
so in the context of this program one of
the key technologies that we're going to
be using and we're going to be talking
about a lot is next generation
sequencing
next generation sequencing could be used
in many different ways
it could be used to analyze individual
genomes like the covet 19 genome it
could be used to analyze meta genomes
where we have a collection of genomes in
a particular sample and we need to
understand diversity or maybe
relationships between these genomes and
also we need to understand the different
types of library preparation techniques
and steps to prepare the data to make
sure that we can answer specific
questions
now to be able to use this data we need
to understand the biology we need to
find the right kinds of data and then we
need to know a variety of techniques
that will make it easy for us
interpret and find meaningful
associations
and that includes understanding of viral
genomics and evolution or phylodynamics
how can we build phylogenetic trees and
monitor progression over time connecting
it with
temporal or maybe different types of
phenotypes that we have understanding of
transcriptomic data or how to find
differences in gene expression and
compare and contrast different types of
conditions or groups of samples
variant calling where we can find
variance in specific positions of on the
genome and be able to interpret them
and analysis of
metagenomic data
data that contains thousands or even
millions of different microorganisms
that need to be categorized and
found relationships between them
the examples you i'm sure that you have
seen
you know in the news and elsewhere but
the examples that we will use in this
program
include
such epidemics like the ebola virus
which you can see right here
the understanding of
origins transmission
replication and development of
continuous evolution in this pandemic
and how it affects our bodies ability to
respond to infection and produce
relevant immune responses
differentiating between specific
processes and stochastic processes
and then linking this understanding
with our ability to take a sample and
monitor the specific types of
clades and variants that are of concern
and ultimately being able to translate
this information
to report on our findings communicating
the results effectively with meaningful
annotation and interpretation
so to summarize what we will do in this
program is we will take a look at
different types of
omics data including genomic
transcriptomic and metagenomic data we
will learn to deal with these data sets
align them
find associations using different types
of processes
interpret them using our understanding
of structure and function of different
genes and proteins and then measure host
responses to really understand how does
the host respond to the different
infections that are there
now data
from next generation sequencing is very
complex this is an alignment of one of
the first sequencing data sets from the
soros cov2
samples that were identified in china
and so as you can see here it's not
trivial to get from this kind of complex
information to some meaningful insights
and so what we will try to do is we will
try to break it down to understand the
principles
behind the data that we have
the analysis methods that help us to
perform some of the functionality in a
semi-automated way
link that with biological understanding
of the processes that drive
the observed variation that we have in
the data and then use analysis methods
that help us
link those into meaningful models
behind the process that we think is
driving this variation
now ultimately we will also talk about
ways to interpret such data not only
find specific variation that is
meaningful but then also use the
appropriate route for interpretation and
we will use the different examples to
link this kind of sequence variation to
actual interaction and function of
different proteins that anyone can do
independently once you find the relevant
meaningful differences in your datasets
now to speak about specific examples of
how this type of bioinformatics approach
can be used to study viruses bacteria
and different types of
pathogens i want to invite our mentors
that will be helping you work through
these different case studies apply these
different technical methods and find
meaningful insights from relevant
biomedical publications i want to
introduce you to our mentors
dr raghavendran ragavandran
is going to be your research consultant
and mentor he's going to be helping you
understand some of these topics and
guide you in the specific case studies
dr prio paul is going to be a teaching
assistant that will help you
understand any kind of technical issues
that you will have throughout this
training and dr mohit mizunder who's
also a project mentor and an expert in
computational biology who will talk
about how sequence and structure poses
some interesting insights and future
directions for this kind of research
so
dr raghav i want to invite you next to
talk about some of the examples that we
discussed
thank you thank you very much elia let
me find a way to share my screen and
yeah i hope my screen is visible to
everybody
yeah
okay perfect yeah i also got uh
confirmation hello everybody one more
time and i'm raghavendran i'm a research
consultant and mentor with pine biot
economics logic i'm trained in
bioinformatics and i hold a phd in
computational biology from max punk
institute of germany my broad research
interests include our my broad research
interests are in the application of data
science methods to understand cancer
biology my role in
find biotech includes developing
curricula for the platform and also
mentoring students in the research
fellowship program and also in the
programs that you'll go to sign up
please allow me to talk about few
example projects that we have prepared
in the platform learn or mix logic
platform that will help you appreciate
how bioinformatics analysis can be
leveraged to understand the biology of
pathogens and to study infectious
diseases
so first we will focus on a project that
studies the current pandemic covid19 so
in this project we explored the
pathogens coronavirus itself and
as well as two diseases that that are
caused by it
so this project will help you explore
the origin of the pandemic and how
different diseases are caused by this
pathogen and how they are related to
existing uh strains from human
coronavirus and also
to other strains from animals uh
sources also so we will do this by using
publicly available data
from repositories like ncbi writers and
geo data etc
so we will learn in this project we have
learned to perform or how to perform
multiple sequence alignment followed by
philo genetic analysis these analysis
will help us compare the existing
strains of coronavirus to understand the
zoonotic origins of the disease so we
will also learn in detail how to
interpret results from
analysis like multiple sequence
alignment to understand mutational
changes in the genome of source code ii
compared to different strains as i have
already told strains from humans and
also strains from different animals
next we will also see uh what are the
important protein components of the
virus through which they enter into the
human cell and we will we will also
learn how to visualize the identified
mutations on the spike protein for
example and from such analysis and such
visualization we can understand and we
can study which mutation might affect
the functional properties of this spike
protein and alter its ability to bind to
the receptor in the host cell so
furthermore we will also
learn how we can look for
transcriptomics data from uh from
patients that are infected with
sarcophagus using uh
public repositories like g gene
expression omnibus database and etcetera
here we will explore uh such data this
data in particular to find out important
transcriptional signatures that are
associated with drug treatments like
root solution
rucks in
short we will also learn some important
bioinformatics methods that are
available for identifying gene
expression signature
for treatments like rooks or rexolidinid
we will perform differential gene
expression analysis between rocks
treated and untreated samples and we
will also employ unsupervised machine
learning methods like principal
component analysis and clustering to
understand the potential of these
signatures
in categorizing drug treated and
untreated samples
so
yeah
during the course of this project you
will learn how to do and the logic
behind such analysis and how to
interpret these analysis in the context
of the
data or in the context of the biological
project or questioning
so next project we will
get introduced to is on the outbreak of
enterovirus d68 or evd68 in short
this is a virus that causes a severe
neurogenic disease called acute flaccid
mellitus afm in short mainly in children
so it is a
in comparison it is a polio-like illness
defined by the acute onset on
spine or on the paralysis of the spine
so in this project we will understand
the evolutionary relationship between
the strains of different outbreaks of
this virus so
to go into the history this virus first
emerged around 1960s and in the last
decade itself the outbreak of ebd68 has
been reported across different parts of
the globe even in developed countries
like united states
europe and roughly once in two years or
once in three years or so on
so their pathogenicity also varies among
these outbreaks and among different
populations of these uh virus
so similar to the sars project here also
we will use various phylogenetic free
reconstruction techniques and algorithms
to find out whether the evd68 strains
from different outbreaks at different
time points like 2014 16 18 are
are from the same virus or from the same
strain or from the different strain or
related virus using
next-gen sequencing data of the patients
so we will also see that phytogenetic
analysis reflects the variations in the
strain that causes these outbreaks in
different years or in different time
points furthermore
multiple sequence alignment will reveal
a number of variations in the sequences
of different viral strains a careful
analysis and how to perform this cash
flow analysis
will help us identify critical mutations
that can cause significant changes in
the amino acid level among these
different strains these mutations can be
related to the virulent properties of
the pathogen and will help us
characterize the viruses like evd 68 or
star scope 2 which is currently
a very dangerous pandemic going on based
on their pathogenesis
hope that was informative and that was
very interesting and i look forward to
meet many of you in the bioinformatics
for infectious diseases program i thank
you very much for your attention and and
will now pass the stage to dr priya
thank you very much
yeah hello everyone
just give me two minutes to share my
screen
so can you see my screen
yes family can see your screen
okay so i'm dr priya opal i'm a research
and curriculum coordinator at find
biotech i did my post doctorate from
indian institute of science bangalore in
uh molecular biology and mathematics
my phd is the life sciences from gnd
omritsa with specialization in stress
physiology and i have 25 publications so
far which are published in journals of
national and international repute
regarding my
justice
[Music]
i'm sorry for the
interruption actually
some network connectivity issue
regarding my research interest
it is a next generation sequencing
cancer biology drug discovery and
repurposing stress physiology and data
science so i'll be talking about uh the
ebola virus outbreak so we all know
about the 2014 2016 outbreak of ebola
virus which occurred in west africa and
it affected thousands of people all
across the world we all know that it is
a viral disease of humans and primates
and it is caused by ebola virus
so to develop the vaccines and antiviral
drugs for this
infectious disease
we need to understand what is the origin
of this virus what is the shape and
structure of this ebola virus so
designed a project on this ebola virus
which is based on original publication
data to understand the origin and to
find out what are the important
mutations or the variants which cause
this lethal outbreak so we got the data
from ncbi platform ncbi virus platform
and we used genome sequence from this
particular platform and we performed
multiple sequence alignment and
palogenetic analysis to determine the
evolutionary relationship between these
genomes
and then we
what we identified was we identified the
groups of samples and so how they are
related to the phenotype so we use t bio
platform server which uh sonalica and uh
ilia and dr agav they've already spoken
about this
so what we analyzed we analyzed
mutations between groups of samples
using comparative analysis to study the
mutability this method helped us to
identify the region of polymorphism
which is believed to cause an increase
in the ability of the virus to enter its
host cell
so this is all from my side and i'm
looking forward to
participation of all the
participants and
maybe coming the upcoming the research
fellowship program so thank you so much
over to use malik
thank you so much dr raghav ainsworth
and dr priya now i would like to invite
dr mohairs to help us understand the
structure
the program structure of bioinformatics
from infectious diseases over to you dr
mohit
am i audible
yes sir
okay so can you see my screen also sorry
for asking yes
no that's perfectly fine yes we can see
us
hello everyone it's great to meet you
all today
i'm mohit and i have a phd in
computational biology
and specialization in molecular modeling
simulations and discovery related
research projects
so in today's session
uh in a few slides
i'll go through the publicly available
data recent structural data from the
pandemic
so talking about that the structural
biology response to the clovin 1910
to the kovit 19 penta pink has allowed
the world to see the virus how i mean
the virus is attacking us in us in a
structural uh
perspective so we can visualize we can
see the structure so it has also aided
in vaccine and therapeutic development
as and has shown four sides in the
investments in structural biology
capabilities in in you know techniques
such as um
such as external crystallography or
techniques such as cryo-em or the mx
so this sheer magnitude and uniqueness
of the event
that has you know uh
that has enabled all of us in a way that
that helped in all these different types
of data that has come out
from different repositories so today we
are going to get an overview of where
this data is and how it looks
so the speed uh with which these
structural inves investigations have
occurred has been really breathtaking
similar simultaneously the availability
of these data have
has benefited from the long history of
making you know these depositories and
the metadata that is also available uh
with this information about the
structural information and all of this
is available in repositories such as
protein data bank
uh a worldwide repository for
macromolecular structures and also we
are going to talk about some other
aspects of getting structure which is
through molecular remodeling so as the
one and there is like this one and a
half year since the declaration
of kovite 19 and
recently 1000 structures of starscope 2
biomolecules have been deposited in the
pdp itself so these are all experimental
structures that have been deposited in
protein data bank
so it is like kind of you know rare to
obtain a snapshot of such immense effort
in structural biology uh and uh this
happened due to this revolution of not
only uh uh not only the
need all the structures but also the
technology so with cryo-em there's there
has been a lot of you know insights that
we got from the
resolution revolution that is what it is
said in aspect of cryo-em
microscopy
so uh talking about the computational
aspect of this so first the experimental
aspect is about the structural biology
events
and experiments that led to the
information of this kind of data that
how how these structures are but still
there are many limitations when we are
talking about the complete understanding
of how
it relates how structure can be related
to the function so there are uh that's
where i mean computational structural
biology a computational structural
bioinformatics comes in so where we are
talking about you know modeling complex
structures to gain insight or to be able
to understand the effect of mutations on
these experimental structures so those
things can be modeled and have been
playing a very important role in
understanding the pandemic more and more
and to find solutions so the source goes
to pandemic as i said
has contributed a lot in terms of also
uh structural biology work so in cell
infrastructure biology work so initially
initially what people were used to do is
i will tell you about some of the
software's that that are available
online tools such as the one that is
listed here uh alpha full
but also there is a software uh that
many of us use for structural
predictions is a ci tester so from zen's
lab so it's a it's an online uh online
available tool and also alpha fold from
deepmind consortium
they have been able to
with these two rules we have been able
to leverage the uh gene relays release
genomes determine protein sequence and
also to create computational models and
this has been happening till the early
march 2020 to till date so some modeling
uh
a lot of insights that we could draw
from structural data is why i modeling
so how do we model complex structures
how do models uh single point mutations
or multiple mutations and understand the
variance
and also then there is an aspect of
molecular dynamic simulations that have
massively also extended the utility of
experimental structural data that helps
in providing insights while the rapid
analysis of you know these in silico
mutagenesis for many key viral proteins
and also to the ability to for example
model glycosal glycosylation of the
spike protein
our computational approach has also
helped in proving uh you know host
pathogen protein interactions so protein
protein interaction
uh and then contributing also in network
network based and machine learning uh
based analysis and we have an upcoming
talk about the network analysis uh
tomorrow uh that uh i would uh like uh
you to all know about psionic club so we
will be sharing that information also
with you
so about the structures and to
understand like what is available out
there and how to understand and make use
of this so that is an important aspect
of integrating structural biology into
your research or you know utilizing the
data that is available publicly so the
spy protein of this virus i mean uh
uh is one of the central figure right in
this fight
since it is the primary target for
antibodies uh to provide and to target
of antibodies that provide immunity
against the virus so the surface of
corona virus says i'll give you a
laymen explanation so the surface of
corona viruses are covered with these
spikes giving them their distinctive
clown-like appearances in the electron
micrographs so many people are already
aware of this and i think most of us are
so the spikes
the spikes initiate the process of
infection binding to the receptor and
then fusing with the cell membrane to
release the viral genome inside that's
the process so many other
and has been seen in many other models
as well like um
influenza
hematoglutinin and also hiv and ebola so
the spike protein is composed you know
of three identical chains that form
together a complex with a small domain
inside uh which is the
which is
inside the virus which is the membrane
spinning segment and there is a there's
a large ectodomain uh and that all you
can see some of those structures that
you can see in this
in this uh slide so this structures also
include a portion of
the mini sugar chain that coats the
spike since the sugars are highly
flexible and difficult to observe that's
one of the challenge so many things that
you can gain inside from
is are the structures
are from the structures
and to tell you more about that so
recent structures have revealed that the
spike of subscribe to and subscribe
so comparing both when you compare both
we we found out that they are quite
flexible so in these structures the
receptor receptor binding domains uh the
receptor binding domain are seen in the
in different conformation so when you
compare structures and when you're
superimposing them on one one another in
a three-dimensional space you can see
the differences and how there is a
movement you can find out about that
movement
just from your you know screen so by
doing by learning about these different
tools that we will be covering in this
entire program so often just one domain
in this case of source code two so
many times what is happening is that one
domain you would see that there is some
movement and then
there are several other extensions that
that you will see that are tucked down
or
i mean there are different type of
movements that have been uh found out in
these different types of confirmation
and then
uh researchers what researchers have
hypothesized that the recent starscope
to where variants are virulent because
their receptor binding domains are
particularly flexible so that's one of
the hypothesis
and whereas most spread corona viruses
that cause the common cold are less
less dangerous because they are less
flexible so that's one of the hypothesis
that you can understand by comparing
some of these structures and understand
from the different conformations
that include
the binding i mean to understand this
this has to be model so you have
structures from different confirmations
that you obtain from different protein
data banks uh structures uh which are
deposited online and then you try to
model them into a complex that will give
you a clear insight of how this is done
so these are some of the things that you
need to learn computationally in
computational biology or in silico
computational structural biology so
about the receptor binding uh our immune
system you know fight backs right when
corona virus infects us so that's where
the antibodies comes in so antibodies
are what are protein molecules that play
a key role in any organism's defense
against a foreign molecule called
antigen right the first step in this
process is specific complex formation
between an antibody molecule and a
molecule of the antigen
so the structural basis of this antibody
antigen recognition is started to
getting illustrated from these
structures so these structures are
helping us to understand that mechanism
how it works
uh so the spike is a major target of
this protection right since it is
exposed to the surface of the virus
and these three proteins i mean these
three protein structures that you can
see on the left which is 3bgf and 2g hw
and 6w41
and you can totally search them by their
four digit keyword to
you just paste them on your browser it
will show you to the link to the
to their actual structure that has been
deposited in the pdp so these are pdb
ids
um so
these three structures um show that the
antibody can be recognized by spiked
proteins in many ways so two of these
antibodies block the receptor binding
portion of the domain but the other
antibody targets a cryptic site at the
base of the domain that is only exposed
when the antibody binds to it so you see
that there are not only just different
conformation but different active sites
also that you can find
that you can see which depends on the
movement of the protein so one thing
that you have to understand is that this
is a pdb is just a snapshot and uh when
a protein is in motion then it is moving
so there are different conformations
that are protein attends and then based
on those different conformation there
could be different strategies to design
molecule so this is something that we
should consider this sort of structural
information is something that we should
consider when we go about you know
designing a vaccine or when we are
looking for strategies to find out
solutions
to uh you know finding drug finding a
drug
so uh about this uh doing all of this is
kind of possible
so in this program we will be learning
to use powerful visualization tools such
as chimera
and explore through the
available structural data
and then also we will we will be
reviewing
several tools developed for your
training in this program
to navigate large data sets and then
connect the various aspects of you know
various aspects of sequence structure
and meta data
into a single experience this is speak
nav
so what it will help us is that it will
help us in understanding or addressing
many questions so genomic data analysis
can be utilized to see the changes
between viral strains so you're looking
at the mutations and different
significance level of these detector
changes and how you track them or map
them to the 3d
position of the on the protein structure
so that you can see whether they are on
the surface whether they are in the
active site what could be the rule
then
we will be using we will be able to do
you know from sequence to structure
another aspect is to do comparison and
that comparison at a sequence level is
could be done through multiple sequence
alignment so multiple sequence alignment
is a very powerful tool to understand
viral adaptation between animals and
protein and again then try trace it back
to the structure
similarly another aspect of answering
some of the research questions would be
to
understand the relationship between
virus viral and host pro host proteins
such as uh the trimeric sas
corona virus surface surface spike
glycol glycoprotein
so this spike glycoprotein
binds to a cellular receptor called
angiotensin converting enzyme to so ace
two i mean you might have like you might
all i've heard about is two in short so
and it mediates through the fusion of
viral and cellular membranes through a
pre to post fusion conformation
translation transitions so as i was
telling you before also so because of
certain binding there are trans uh you
know there are conformational changes
that enables another binding event so
all of this fascinating stuff and
you and and just imagine to be able to
visualize it and to understand from
sequence level to a structural level is
something that we are planning uh for
this uh program and uh we're hoping that
many of you can go through that
experience and understand different
aspects of how structure and complexes
that mapping mutations
from a single protein from a population
to the three-dimensional structure and
understanding the function obviously is
something that we're trying to
help
everyone to learn
so this is what we have planned for the
structural part and that's what i wanted
to tell you all about in today's session
and we will be covering these these in
much more detail when we go through
these different case studies that will
be covered covered in the full training
program uh starting from 14 february and
that's about my part of the presentation
and uh
to tell you more about the entire
schedule of this program and how the
sessions will be and how you could all
register i'll now hand it over to uh mr
nalika
thank you so much dr mohit for such a
wonderful presentation
now i would like to take you all through
uh the registration page to get yourself
enrolled for the program commencing on
14th of february
and this is the link to the program page
i'll be pasting it up in the chat box
also we'll be mailing out the link to
the program page along with the
uh link to the recording of the session
to you all after the session
so once you are here on the program page
you will find all the details that are
related to the program that includes a
program overview and most important of
all the schedule for the program
so here you'll find all the session
dates and also the sessions let me just
zoom in sorry
yes here you will be able to find all
the session dates along with each and
every topic of the session
and also the topics that are supposed to
be covered in the sessions along with
the associated online resources so for
each and every session uh there are some
online associated resources that
includes the links to the lessons on the
army logic learn portal and also some
mental guided resources that you will be
supposed to go through along with each
session
once the session is completed once each
session is completed we will be sending
you out the link to these associated
resources and also the recorded sessions
in case you miss out on the session or
uh want to revise the session you will
get the recording as well as the
associated resources and publications
that are to be followed along with the
session itself
now when you scroll down on the program
page itself you will find three levels
two uh like which you can refer to
enroll yourself for the program the
first level is a beginner level which
includes the access to live q a sessions
group sessions and also the recordings
the access to almost logic clone portal
and the t bio info server educational
pipelines then we have an intermediate
level
which will give you an access to
one-on-one mentor support and then we
have an advanced level where you will
get some extra time
to figure out a research proposal with
the help of the mentor you will be able
to
explore some of the data sets from the
big data repositories and you'll be able
to come up with a research proposal that
you can further work upon
in the research fellowship program and
get yourself a publication or at least
present your your research work in a
poster presentation uh format that is in
the upcoming symposium that is scheduled
for march 31st and april 1st
so these are the three levels beginner
intermediate in advance that you can uh
opt for and you simply need to click on
the sign in and checkout button and you
will also be uh given the access to the
early bird discount coupon code via
emails i believe so our marketing
executives firsthand will send you a
market um
a coupon code that will give you the
access to the early bird offer with
which you you can definitely enroll in
the program picking up any of the levels
that you would like to enroll for
and when you scroll down
you will also get the list of program
course and project library that includes
the associated coursework that you are
supposed to go through as a part of the
program which includes our mislogic
courses and example projects which will
help you understand how the key concepts
methodologies and the pipelines that you
went through could be applied to answer
a real life research problem and get
some hands-on practice
and yes definitely many of you had a
question about the certification process
so once you successfully complete the
program you will be accredited with the
certificate
and
this was the like this was all the
information that was required for you to
know about the registration process and
we have the link shared with all of you
now if any one of you has any questions
please put them up in the chat box so
that we can answer
[Music]
okay so muhammad is asked asking is
there any programmer analyzing cancer
data i would like dr mohit uh to take
this question specifically because i
think uh he's the best person to answer
it uh nicely what do to your doctor
okay so dr mohit i think is not here
yes so when you say cancer data
specifically you are referring to the
oncology field right so yes we
definitely have a lot of programs uh
that includes the uh analysis and the
understandings first of all and then
definitely to get some hands-on practice
with this type of data so when you say
cancer data or let's say the oncology
field then comes the role of either
transcriptomic data analysis or genomic
data analysis that you can go through
and learn about right or even
metagenomic data analysis could be
explored and learned about as we have
had recently a lot of publications are
telling how metagenomics
data could be explored to understand the
plant uh the patterns that are
responsible for causing a cancerous
condition
so yes so when you say oncology then we
have three programs specifically that is
genomic data analysis metagenomic data
analysis and also the transatomic data
analysis and having the knowledge of
these particular skill sets you can
definitely apply these skill sets to the
specialization track of oncology and
mohammed uzair khan i'll recommend you
if you can just simply put your mail id
in the chat box and uh you'll get the
list of these programs that you can
explore you like you can see what all uh
topics these programs includes and what
exactly would you like to explore and
learn from and get some hands-on
practice so just put your mail id and
we'll be able to help you out with that
omovami is asking how many session how
many hours uh are the session and the
time please
so um for me uh the
like the sessions will be uh an hour and
a half each though they are scheduled
for an hour but uh because we have
discussions with the program
participants definitely it gets extended
to an hour and a half or maybe two at
max and these sessions are scheduled for
9 00 am cst you can convert it to your
time zone and see what exact time it
becomes and uh
also let's say you are you are not
available at 9am cst and you're not able
to make up to the live session then you
can definitely go through the recorded
session and take up your questions in
the slack channel so we have slack
channel for each and every program that
we have and you can take your questions
in the slack channel you will also have
the mentors up there and uh
follow the
recordings specifically in that way
and uh for the session schedule please
refer the program page here you have all
the dates listed and also you have all
the topics listed for each and every
date
uh dr raghavendran you are here with us
right
we have a specific question that i would
uh like you to address
the question is by saurabh roy he's
asking i would like to ask if there is
any blockchain based technology
available for bioinformatics or any
in development
oh
that's a toughie
i mean more